تعال
[موسيقى]
سفات نحن الان في مدرسه سكينه او بجوار
مدرسه سكينه التي استهدفتها على المدفعيه
قبل قليل طبعا المدرسه تحتوي على عدد كبير
من النازحين هذ هي مكان
الاستهداف يعني
هنا
الصور للمكان الذي
استهدفته المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه هذا هو
كان يحتوي على عدد كبير من النازحين
نازحين احنا قاعدين في امان قاعدين نشحن
جوالاتنا في الساحه مادرين الا صاروخ
بينزل في نازحين نازحين امنين مدرسه كلها
اطفال كلها شيوخ مكسحين لا لهم لا ان في
جناء عسكري ولا غيره نازحين رمونا مناشير
وتوجهنا على دير البلح هذا المكان الامن
اللي بتوفر لنا اياه ومين اللي نزل مقطع
نساء واطفال ولا واحد زلمه كان في الغرفه
قالوا لنا تعالوا امانين وهينا وصلنا هذا
هم في درلا احنا في الشم في بيت لاهيه
وخلونا هلقيت امونا هلقيت بيضربوا علينا
قداف من الصبح ليش وش حرام عليهم